well our daughters are about the same
age does she get to travel with you
because you get to travel so much yes
but I'm finding now that she's I find it
really inconvenient that she's at school
I wanted to come out and play with Me
Mine finds it inconvenient too she wants
to go with me yeah yeah they got to that
age where you kind of have to respect
their education yeah you know which is
pretty difficult but I'm gonna try and
bring her a bit more and maybe bring a
tutor or something because coming to
things like this for her to see us our
girlies seeing us working and how
important that's an education yeah that
women are just like I'm getting out
there so I I agree with that too it is
obviously we love school too but I love
school they're important so wait does
she know like when you were traveling
does she know that her mom once got
kicked out of a hotel I don't know what
you're talking about
so look look
there if you're going to leave a Hostess
trolley in a corridor when people have
had a little beverage you're inviting
trouble you were inviting trouble so I
lay on top of it my friend laid like
through it and another friend of ours
like pushed us down the corridor and we
accidentally smacked into this you know
the wheels are like
yeah smacked into this thing and this
woman opens the door and goes well thank
you very much I just got my baby to
sleep and we had to go downstairs and
sign a thing saying we'd never come back
to the hotel yeah
here's my thing I heard this story and I
was like that got you kicked out yes do
you know what kinds of things I have
seen and heard on tour I got like I
can't even I was like wow yeah a lot of
people I know would have yeah I'm not
happy and I actually thought they would
get because I was there to do all my
fittings for for Spamalot on Broadway
yeah and I thought oh my God they're
gonna think I'm an English reprobate but
nothing happened to the show honestly
yeah not good
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm going home
[Music]